[Music]
all right let's go to danielle in
reading pennsylvania hey danielle what's
up
hi there how are you
well i'm a little stressed at the moment
so i'm calling to get some advice all
right
my adult daughter and her two children
are living in my house
and she has always had a
tendency to do things
impulsively and there's been
a shortage of maturity i will also add
to
some issues that we've had
and
recently she has now started a new
relationship
and i've i've seen some things that i
don't like in her
and i feel like i want her to move out
of my house but i don't want it to be
you got to get out i
i need
maybe some guidance on how to work this
out because i want her to get out of my
house yeah
i just tell you thank you for your
spirit and thank you for loving your
baby girl and also this is hard but
thank you for
having boundaries
and all of those feel like they're in
tension with one another another and
they are but they're not all mutually
exclusive so you're heading into some
choppy waters but they're the right
waters and so good for you so why did
she come move into your house
she
this is one of the impulse things
she
went and kind of eloped let's say with
someone she had been seeing for a short
time
um i'm gonna say about two years or two
and a half years into it he up and left
and left her with
her daughter and their
one-year-old at the time and she wasn't
generating enough income and i would
never let my loved ones just live in the
streets so certainly come home sure and
i i didn't feel like you know you have
three months you have six months and she
hasn't been making money but i i will
take
i will take the responsibility and say i
think that i have let it drag on too
long there you go
because i've seen her
not
become more responsible and be
taking steps to move out she's quite
comfortable and and now i feel like
you're
not just comfortable but you're taking
things for granted and you're enabling
me
there you go so here's what i want you
to do
i want you to
write her a letter
and i want you to go by yourself and it
may take a couple hours it may take a
couple of days it may take five drafts
one draft i don't i don't i don't care
but just get it right
and i want you to have a couple of parts
in this letter the first one is i want
you to tell her
how important she is to you
how much you love her the things that
you see in her life that you are proud
of her about i want you to let her know
that and it's important that you write
this down and i'll tell you why but then
i want you to talk about
here's how i've loved you stepped in the
gap and here's the next way i'm going to
love you which is i'm going to walk
alongside you as you leave the nest
and i want you to take her out somewhere
we joke here at the office i'm always
telling people to go to breakfast our
friend anthony like to have these
conversations at dinner
um i think better in the morning so i
like breakfast but i want you to take
her somewhere and i want you and it may
not even be in a restaurant it may be in
a private place but i want you to read
her this letter and then hand it to her
and here's why
when people are in this situation as
soon as they start to get a hint that
i'm going to be homeless
or
less less specific i'm getting abandoned
again i'm getting left again
their brain shifts their critical
thinking literally goes offline and
their fight or flight takes over and so
they start hearing things
as that are not always real when you
write it down and hand it to him she can
re-read it and re-read it and re-read it
and then eventually get to the okay my
mom even if i don't agree with it
in my mom's heart she loves me and she's
trying to walk alongside me i want you
to stay on the line i'm gonna give you a
copy of total money makeover by dave and
i want you to give that to her as a gift
i want you to help her make a budget i
want you to give her a ramp say in three
months i'm gonna i'm gonna go with you
to look at apartments i'm gonna go with
you to look at little at rental home
whatever that looks like i'm gonna help
you with your job i'm gonna walk
alongside you
but at this deadline
is when we're moving out